[Music]
is the west
you can define it however you wish
losing its cultural influence as well as
its economic dominance so with the
turning in of some societies and u.s no
longer the beacon that it was the shiny
city on the hill perhaps some argue that
the west is losing its influence and not
just economically to kick us off
cindy
wow it was a very big question and i i'm
afraid i have to can only talk about it
from the chinese perspective because i
think for us sitting in the west talking
about the decline of the west especially
the decline of western cultural
influence it's very hard to say because
we don't see
how the rest of the world sees the west
um hollywood again going back to
hollywood
remains a massive force at least in
china um but i don't know how much it's
declined in recent years in other
countries so i i have to say starting
out from the caveat um
what china sees what's interesting and
going back to my previous point about
hubris is that
in recent decades in china you might
think this is a good thing or a bad
thing china the chinese have become more
confident in their own cultural exports
so what do i mean by that i mean that
when we talk about luxury fashion so for
example in the 90s you might have
chinese people coming out looking for
chanel and burberry today's millennials
and generation generation zed's they
love chinese brands and they don't care
about chasing the same western um soft
power labels that their parents did and
that's a fascinating development and you
might think you necessarily fashion but
actually it betrays a deeper cultural
confidence in itself china hasn't really
had cultural confidence in itself in the
last couple of centuries it's been
going through a lot of stuff
and so you know you end up with phrases
like um chong yang meiwei you know
loving the west in favor of the chinese
but i see that turning on its head now
and luxury fashion as an example uh in
recent years the highest grossing films
in china have all been chinese with the
exception of avengers end game so you
know some things do cut through um but
what's interesting is that as china
rises um its own cultural exports are
becoming more um what it looks for so
and linda i know you wanted me to touch
on ways in which china is doing well as
well around the world um so you know
things like belt and road initiative we
talked about and of course peter is
right that a lot of these debt traps
leave countries in not very good
positions and we've heard about um sri
lankan ports being you know carved out
and all this sort of stuff but it's also
the case that um a lot of these
recipients of belt and road initiative
funding are not countries that the west
is interested in so when was the last
time that the uk did anything with
pakistan in terms of investment
so when was the last time that the uk
cared anything about africa you know we
earlier this year we had a debate about
the foreign aid budget cut
so it looks as if in a lot of these
places where perhaps because of the fall
of colonialism and imperialism the west
is withdrawing into itself with the
exception of tackling islamic extremism
perhaps whereas china is looking into
going to all of these places like
morocco like south africa like southeast
asia and giving them vaccines giving
them investments and that is one way in
which china is exporting its influence
but the question is about cultural
influence and this is the interesting
point i don't think it is exporting its
cultural influence except in cultures
that are already quite similar to itself
so in south korea japan southeast asia
there's a lot of consumption of chinese
soft power but outside of that it's not
this case that mandarin for example has
become
the language that everyone seeks to
speak i don't know if any of you have
even heard of chinese pop music and
certainly in a lot of parts of the world
that's not an export at all
so
yeah to go back to the question you know
i don't think
when it comes to cultural influence in
china the west is losing its cultural
influence in favor of a more confident
chinese cultural native export but that
doesn't mean china is doing any better
in itself in exporting its own in other
parts of the world um with the exception
of hard power you know investments roads
infrastructure vaccines that sort of
stuff and you know even that has as
peter's pointed out mixed success
thank you cindy i want to come to peter
back on these issues but phil let me
bring you in it sounds like what cindy
is arguing is that
from the chinese perspective they're
looking more to their own culture so
that is a relative decline of western
culture um but what is your take on this
yeah that's true um and there's an
obvious economic reason for that and
it's interesting you mentioned chanel
cindy because i've always thought coco
chanel is not given the credit she
deserves in diplomatic circles for being
a major political figure and the reason
i think that is that the chanel company
were
very serious collaborators with the
nazis they were absolutely they did
their work by essentially um being
complicit with national socialist
germany but then the chanel products
were a very very important part of what
glittered in the windows in berlin
during the cold war and that
consumerism was a very important part of
it the cultural artifacts though were
the embodiment of an economic disparity
they were the the ways in which you
could see visibly that on this side of
the wall there was prosperity and on
this side of the wall there were cues
now that's not true
now we've got a rival economic system to
the western liberal democratic
capitalist system which on its own terms
is doing very well that's the
fundamental difference so you can have
the cultural confidence in the knowledge
that you can pay for it you can fund it
so that's the central question i mean i
i hesitate to be too deterministic about
it but it takes you back to the economic
success and so long as we that china is
able to continue its economic success
whilst also denying its people the
political liberties which are the usual
accompaniment of economic success then
it can have a cultural confidence if
that compact breaks down then it won't
i gotta get your reply to that cindy
before we come to theater no i think i
think phil's right and i think you know
cultural exports last have a lasting
impact after economic advantage goes so
you know it's i guess i'm not a class
assistant people might correct me on
this but you can see the impact
influence of the greeks on the roman
empire even after the greece was become
had become a region to be administered
by the roman empire so i think these
cultural artifacts and you know even in
the british empire you know the soft
power that we willed in america is not
corresponding really to our economic
advantage at the moment so the question
is how long does that last um and i
think china is at its very peaks and
there's an interesting question which we
might come onto later about how much
china will continue to grow
how much its growth is sustainable
especially in this week's um evergrand
uh you know the property estate agents
which is maybe defaulting um in china so
you know the question is is that a
career for china or is that lehman
brothers for china so how sustainable is
this economic growth and if it doesn't
quite make it in this case my point of
hubris if it's if the chinese get
overconfident before they make it to
superpowered him what does that mean and
i think that's a very interesting um
situation to be in
peter
one of the conundrums that we face is
that
china is
ostensibly communist in name
but essentially
a state-controlled capitalism in reality
so you could say that even in china the
western model has triumphed
um
you know in china today there are nearly
400 billionaires i think almost as many
as the united states
um there are huge disparities between
rich and poor
you've got the immense riches of the
major cities
and still in the more rural areas
people are being forced off their land
to make way for new cities and motorways
with bare compensation
so you have this incredible
contradiction between what china claims
to be
and what it actually is
and what has been very interesting is
being the revival
of a new form of maoism in parts of
china
to counter these huge disparities in
wealth and power and the increasing
repression of nascent independent trade
unions
in china as well
where labour activists have sought to
challenge you know harsh working
conditions lack of health and safety low
wages and so on and been very heavily
repressed
to look at
what the west is doing that is good and
which has
some potential to maintain cultural
influence and i would say not that i'm
advocating the west but i'm advocating
liberal progressive values which of
course are shared by people in all
countries and all cultures
um
if we look at some of our development
aid
some of it is tied to exports and has a
ulterior motive
but some of it is genuinely linked to
ngos doing great work to
you know provide clean water
sanitation
farming implements for poor communities
that is a very positive way in which
western or liberal values are being
maintained or exported or encouraged in
other countries
we also have great institutions like the
bbc
one of the most trusted news services in
the world which
many many millions of people around the
world tune into
to circumvent the state control and
censorship of their own media
we have the great work of the british
council you know which
promotes cultural debates and
discussions in many countries
i'm not saying these are perfect by a
long shot
but
on the whole they are a force for good
and then we have football you know um
football in this country has been a
great um
i suppose
internationalizer something you know you
you've got people all over the world who
follow
british football teams
and even in china yeah and football is a
great leveler you know it brings people
together
and transcends political economic and
cultural differences
um there is the fact that the english
language
is
the most universal in the world and
again a great unifying factor and of
course this can be used for bad as well
as for good
but i think
the cultural influence of western
countries
is still there and it is still
significant
and so therefore i would very much
caution
against albeit the rise of islamism and
right-wing populism
i would very much caution against the
idea that the west is
losing out culturally we are not as
influential as we once were and that is
probably a good thing although not in
terms of those negative alternative
movements
thank you peter i think
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas
you